Danielle Kadjo.
- Tout a commencé par un simple
câble. André Chagnon en avait
compris le secret et la portée.
Cet électricien de Montréal
choisit en 1966 d'orienter
son entreprise vers
la câblodistribution.
C'est la naissance d'un empire.
D'abord implanté dans
un seul quartier de Montréal,
Vidéotron câble des dizaines
de milliers de foyers québécois
et fait l'acquisition
d'autres entreprises
grâce à la Caisse de dépôt
et placement du Québec qui
en finance la majeure partie.
- La présence de la Caisse de
dépôt, à cause de sa crédibilité
dans le secteur financier,
de la qualité de ses placements
et le fait d'avoir investi
dans Vidéotron en 79, ça nous
apportait automatiquement
la crédibilité.
- En 1986, coup d'éclat :
Vidéotron fait l'acquisition
de Télémétropole, la première
chaîne de télévision privée
au Québec. Puis, André Chagnon
cède les rennes de l'entreprise
à son fils Claude.
Sous sa gouverne, le conglomérat
est vendu à Québécor.
Deux ans plus tard, André
et sa femme Lucie décident
d'investir une bonne partie
de ce gain dans le secteur
philanthropique pour soutenir
la santé, l'éducation et
la réduction de la pauvreté.
- La réussite scolaire, c'est
d'avoir plus de citoyens en
santé, réduction de décrochage
scolaire, permettre à des gens
d'avoir de meilleurs emplois,
de meilleurs revenus, des gens
plus en santé, moins de
pauvreté, et des citoyens
qui se prennent en main.
- La Fondation Chagnon
voit le jour en 2000 et
son combat n'a jamais fléchit.
En 2015, l'Assemblée nationale
du Québec a notamment décerné
à sa femme et lui une médaille
d'honneur pour leur parcours
de vie.
ALBAN D'AMOURS, adm. sociétés,
Fond. Lucie et André Chagnon
- Sa passion pour l'être humain.
C'est ça que je retiens de lui.
Il a utilisé tous les moyens,
en particulier les moyens
financiers, son savoir-faire
dans ce domaine-là,
pour venir en aide aux gens.
- Sur Twitter, le premier
ministre du Québec François
Legault parle d'un homme
brillant et visionnaire.
"En fondant l'entreprise
de câblodistribution Vidéotron,
M. Chagnon a façonné le Québec
d'aujourd'hui", écrit-il.
Pierre Karl Péladeau parle
d'un homme pour lequel son père
avait une grande estime,
"qui a su reconnaître
l'importance du secteur
des télécommunications
pour le bénéfice des Québécois."
André Chagnon a toujours su
préserver la philosophie
et l'éthique qui ont fait
son succès, tant dans
ses orientations sociales
que dans ses entreprises.
- J'ai un principe dans la vie :
si tu frappes continuellement
sur le même clou, quelque part,
tu vas avoir des résultats.
- Ici Danielle Kadjo,
Radio-Canada, Mo